hey welcome people of the internets
today is an awesome day for me i get to
be with one of my heroes dr chip dodd
from nashville tennessee here
and we're gonna be talking about mental
health our own journeys
and anything else we stumble into so
let's give me a couple of nerds and so
if you want to check out peace out this
is going to be awesome
so um and we just met we just we already
know each other that's why it's so great
it makes my heart feel good yes um
so yeah i got a i got a phd in 2010
in education and was just an
administrator in
colleges and universities and then i had
a
i just ran head on to this thing where
suddenly my body wasn't acting like i
always
wanted it to and that was my first run
in with anxiety
my first run in with performance and
this is
you do these things and you achieve and
that's where your value comes from
and so i stumbled literally back into a
new job into a new place
and ended up nickel and diming my way
towards a second phd in counseling
i had to know what had happened to me
and all of my work with my students
it just shifted almost overnight about a
decade ago to
from i want to graduate to i think i'm
going to kill myself
and i didn't have the tools um and so it
was a an abrupt shift
and that's been my journey the last
decade and so
then i got as we were talking offline
my research was about um the mental
health of doctors
and lawyers and preachers really and
um the dave ramsey's of the world those
folks that if they're not well
they take down thousands i cannot
believe
right i'm saying this because i started
the center for professional excellence
in 1996
with one premise that if we treat
the influencers the social servants of
society they're healthy we're all good
if they're sick we're all in trouble can
you believe that geniuses and
and geniuses as long as we're in the
black people right but and the focus was
on
medicine mm-hmm academia theology and
jurisprudence
yeah can you believe that those are my
exact ones
lawyers doctors did you find out that
pastors and doctors phys physicians
are more similar in terms of their
mental shape
than other professions because they they
tend to spike on
a lot of people may not understand so i
don't know if i need to say it but
psychopathic deviance and mania
they're certain that they're right yes
no matter what they'll do whatever it
takes to be
to succeed to be right right well the
the where where i found it shift and yes
a thousand percent and even college
presidents are very similar yeah
um they tend to college presidents and
attorneys tend to come from
what i would call knowledge centric
bases right they are constantly mining
the world for more info
whereas a doctor and a pastor has the
info
and their job is to bestow upon it yeah
right there's a sense of elevation and
power
absolutely i i became fast deep in
security
oh my gosh it becomes unmooring right
um i became really passionate about it
from a different lens
i noticed that as i moved through the
higher ed leadership circle
as my friends got promoted we couldn't
hang out anymore
and i understood why because if some
knucklehead
sends a facebook post from the wrong
house
this i was a liability as a friend
or as a friends of mine who were
graduating in med school and they were
physicians
and they started doing physician-y
things or i was a dean of students at a
law school
and all they wanted to do was to you
know depose the poor registered
woman at the register right they became
so
lonely and they had nobody in their
world to
bump up against yeah and i was
recognizing myself
holy smokes dude you are you have nobody
who keeps you accountable to lonely or
when somebody doesn't
agree with you i dismiss them because i
had the academy they're a threat or
you're above them that's right yeah
and it just was and suddenly yeah i
think
i think we have a pathology of i did
this thing
the the five pitfalls of leadership and
which
i bet you'll find extremely familiar if
your work becomes your worth
you've already started on the path of
being in trouble right your
performance matters more than your
person or your presence
right right and then uh people become
objects
yeah in terms of the tools they're
people you have to
you're always having to move people
around or tools then secrets take over
because you're not getting your needs
met anywhere that's right
so you live you live behind the scenes
and nobody knows
right and then finally you're isolated
and at that point
and then when you do stupid things when
we're isolated absolutely yeah whether
it's
suicide or get caught with into your
addiction
somewhere else that's right yes we're
created to be known
that's right i wrote the voice of the
heart i mean it says that you and i are
created as emotional
and spiritual creatures neuroscience
backs this up
left and right now finally i know right
now it's finally i'm like yeah
and you know what neuroscience is
confirming they'll they'll they'll mess
it up i'm sure
but neurofi science is confirming the
truth
of ancient scripture and i did this
thing called the ladder of success
okay and if the way you're born as you
know
you know the apgar is a testimony of the
way we're birthed and that's made to
grow you know you're made to cry
out reach out and take in okay and jesus
says
you know when you're grown it's like you
do not receive because you do not ask he
said
ask and you shall receive you know seek
and you will find and knock and the door
will be opened to you
well that's that's staying in the app
car in a mature way
cry out ask and we'll receive right yeah
and
seek and you will find which means reach
out okay and then knock and the door
will be open to you it's like take it in
so you can grow and go
yeah right so that's not that's not made
the change but what happens is our
society
cultivates uh how am i doing
culture self-esteem rather than what am
i doing with my worth
so we climb the ladder of how am i doing
and so i'm only as good as you say i am
right so we
we practice becoming independent from
how we're created
we we say reality says it is what it is
if you can't take it get out of the way
so i'm better than you and then uh uh
the idea of that power
makes me somebody mm-hmm so we climb the
ladder and so we're in competition with
everyone and compared to everybody
all day long yeah not until we fall off
the ladder
if we're fortunate we fall from seven
wrongs
right but if you climb the ladder to the
top all of us have found out there's
just more ladder that's right
the latter it's eternal just keeps going
you go from being freshman to senior
ever
you know but if you fall it the begin
the end of your life is the beginning
well in the talk but the taller the
ladder gets the more people you land on
when you fall
absolutely yeah the more people are hurt
along the way more people you knock off
right along the way but then when we
come to the place where we
we can say how am i doing from the
standpoint of yes i want to hear
feedback
but the real question of our lives is to
say what am i doing
what am i doing where am i coming from
where am i headed who's going to help me
what am i feeling
what's the truth about what's happening
in my heart and who do i tell
mm-hmm do you know because because
nobody knows how to live until you get
here
and you have to learn along the way so
right when you figure it out you're out
yeah exactly when you figure it out
you're done and you you can't tell
anybody
and they have to learn themselves that's
right i mean machines
we can create to have knowledge after
we're here before we're here right
okay but every child who is born
comes in having to do it all over again
right so
dependency is the key
good healthy dependency is the key that
unlocks the treasure trove of living
fully
and we pathologize dependencies yeah as
though you're broken
yeah something's wrong with a needing
community right for being needy
and we're created for need and that's
how children become ashamed they are
told something's wrong with you for your
tears right
and remember the song
it's a small world it's a world of
laughter and a world of tears
it's a world of hope and a world of
fears
so don't you think it's time we're aware
that hey
we're all alike 99.9 dna
is identical right we're emotionally
spiritually created identically
and yet we practice doing everything we
can to hide from how we're made
we've begun to pathologize basic
humanity
you've been around longer than me when
did this start
and and they they always ask me about
big words
pathologize that feeling sad right
yeah means you're broken what's amazing
is it's
as old as we are and it's as new
as about 19
oh let's see there's something
when we when industry the id the idea of
industrialization kind of moved us
towards this is all going to fix it and
then
industrialization pharmacy science
didn't fix it
and then we have sort of like a
post-modern breakdown
there is no fix so then we're all alone
and there's your truth my truth instead
of a consistent truth so that
that just grows us to separate from each
other okay and then
um addiction becomes actually an answer
not faith
fills the gap yeah because it's to feel
means to need right
and god's gone okay so industrialization
post-modernism and all these things kind
of
has removed god from the picture and our
struggle from then on
has been will we use our brains our
frontal lobe
to speak what's happening in the darker
region the heart will use our frontal
lobe to express our hearts
or we use our frontal lobe to hide our
hearts
because the frontal lobe is always
saying is it safe is it safe is it safe
so if i find out it's safe i can ask the
second question do you care
gotcha do you care do i matter are you
with me
because we're born we're literally born
looking
for who's looking for us right we're so
made for relationships that's right
we're totally co-related yeah we are
yeah i mean it's it
is astounding to me and because we've
been wounded
because we've been raised in ignorance
ignoring what's happening
because we've been raised to be ashamed
because we've been raised in
dissociative worlds
we vow to work against how we're created
so it won't that you know the the the
bad things won't happen again we won't
be rejected we will still
matter yeah so we start climbing that
ladder of being more powerful and
performing more and
or the climbing the ladder of not caring
yeah it's just getting away from the
heart
so on a journey to work with folks who
[Music]
were over a bunch of stuff and found
themselves alone
i also began to notice that same
challenge
in the fancy nerd world as they call it
secondary traumatic stress right
folks like you folks like marsha you
who are in helping professions who take
other people's bricks for a living
30 years of addiction work 30 years of
what i would call
high level intellectual sparring with
smart folks
[Laughter]
the to quote vandal cult um
or vanderkolt the body keeps the score
you wear some of this
how over the last 20 30 years have you
kept yourself whole
that was a great question the cool thing
was in this intellectual sparring
just to speak to that first is that i
would let these guys know
look you're smarter than i am tougher
than i am probably more moral
because you lasted longer you know right
and these guys go to harvard they go to
stanford
they go to these places and yet guys
sitting there with his liver distended
he's 56 year old looks like an 85 year
old man
right he's smarter than i am he is
tougher than i am right
and he was able to keep the secret
that's a form of morality as crazy as it
sounds
he knew what was right or wrong and he
could hide the wrong
right and people didn't know right and
yet i say you but
i've got something you don't have yeah
i've got heart i sleep at night
well yeah i sleep at night you know
sometimes sometimes but i have heart
i have what you had to leave behind i
got back
i have recovery of how i was created
okay i can use
my brain to express my heart i'm
connected it's called integrated
when your head and heart work together
when the parent and the child grow up
right it's integration you know so
that's number one
number two uh i i have a real
passion uh i'm 30 years into this
and i'm not burned out and i'm not worn
out i get tired as heck of course yeah
plus i'm old but real
real really old
that's so funny but anyway so i don't
know why i lie to myself about that
but uh i think i'm just shocked that i'm
old
but this this when i
got when i became awakened to how we're
really made
it became a drum beat inside of me like
i want to do whatever i can to help
people see who they're made to be so
they can do what they're made to do
so that's number number two i mean it's
a passion right which means i'm willing
to be in pain for something that matters
more than pain it's competing this
little drum yeah i'm gonna beat it till
i die thank god i've got something to
to to care about keep going right right
the third thing is
about um two years ago
two and a half years ago uh i've moved
out of the addictions world to
focus on advancing wellness with
chip.com from here on out okay
but it hit me the toll the toll
addiction okay the world had taken on me
i had become uh hard
and i don't mean hard as in hard-hearted
but in terms of like uh harsh
because uh i knew and could see this
thing's killing you
and i'm not sitting around and watch it
happen
so and so that sort of became my like
i'm not sitting around watching this
happen and i became
like uh right on the edge of unmerciful
for anybody who didn't see
that they needed help with something so
i would
i would a little bit ferocious with the
ego okay
and sometimes i'd bash into the right
you know a little
a little tough what what what called you
on that
uh or who called you on that the friends
okay the people around me said dude
you're
you're like you're like that's too much
okay i'm like
and it was my own powerlessness in the
midst of all of that and i kept seeing
people die
i mean i mean the hope in the age of
addiction is a group very powerfully
hopeful book but it's also about the
the titanic sinking like we were doing
some podcasts with the other author
and we were about to leave the problem
for the solution
and i said before we depart the problem
i've got to sit here for just a minute
stephen this guy stephen james
i said i need to sit for a minute
because i'm in a lifeboat
i can hear the water moving around me my
oars are up
it's cold as heck and i'm i can see in
the distance i'm far enough away not to
be sucked into it
but i'm watching the ship on fire and
i'm watching it sink the titanic
and it's the titanic of addiction and
there are people
who wouldn't get off the boat and all
they're doing is moving deck chairs
around
and they're playing the piano and i've
got to sit here and grieve for a minute
before i roll away
because i've spent my my my career
rolling towards the titanic
right and now it's like i mean
if we do not have a revolution
of neediness and a revolution of feeling
our culture genuine feeling not
reactions to feelings
because right now we live in a culture
that says i've got a feeling you've got
a problem
right instead of i've got a feeling and
can you help me right
so i mean i don't mean to be negative
but i am
prescient i am i've seen i'm not living
in denial and i'm not dissociated
but to a culture and denial and a
culture that's dissociated
they're not seeing it they're not seeing
the truth right i mean
if you saw the addiction numbers i hope
you i hope you'll get that book
honestly i'll get it the addiction
numbers john the addiction numbers are
going to
make you stare in shock about what's
happening in our culture we'll do
anything to keep from feeling
and that's how far away we we've moved
from literally how we're created i i
heard a reframe the other day that was
that was pretty powerful was about is
november
um which feels like 150 years ago
but it's when when um jama's
article the general american medical
association came out and said for the
third year in a row
um the average u.s life expectancy had
dropped again
and they framed it and i love this they
are now framing it as diseases of
despair
you may have heard that which was
addiction and suicide
and the third it was the big one was
organ disease failure
and they've now taken liver disease and
heart disease and
said this is just long tail suicide
amazing have you seen lynch's book no
the medical consequences of loneliness i
believe
no what he said this this
now i i sort of teased all of this out
he's he's done the book twice he did
started a longitudinal study
i think in the 70s and he came back in
2013 and
digging an alarm yeah he said
that that heart disease and not being
able to live fully in relationship are
correlated
yeah okay that when a person is talking
and not telling the truth
about what's happening within them
cortisol goes up which you know is
yeah and when a person is not talking
and withholding the truth same thing
blood pressure cortisol
the effects of heart disease but when a
person
like you and i right now i mean i feel
completely at home
with you i feel interested in what i'm
doing you look like
you're i'm interested i'm a good looking
guy yeah yeah
yeah yeah you forgot what a good looking
guy you are and
way younger and a super nerd
super nerdy that's right yeah but i mean
i'm interested
in what we're talking about and based
upon your
i am too yeah and so when the truth is
being spoken
blood pressure goes down right so it's
heart healthy
yeah to be connected truthfully in heart
to other interested people because we're
made to delight in each other
we're made to be curious about each
other's hearts curious about like
who are you how did you get here and
what happened right out of empathy
because i know what it's like to be
human and guess what i know it's like to
be in pain so i can have a
passion for yours compassion we're made
to delight we're made to be curious
we're also made to stand in each other's
way and that's what that's what my
my life into addictions treatment world
was i'm standing in your way
i've already been where you're where
you're headed yeah and you don't have to
go there
so i was very much involved in the
compassion piece
you know and then finally i'm willing to
hurt
but not be harmed gotcha by you yeah
which entails all kinds of things
so i mean we're made for that those four
things
make up love and those four things make
up community
are you married you get kids yeah answer
this
as as much as you feel like it yeah
um how have they
worn and or absorbed your work over the
years
or have or how have you shielded them
from your world you know what that
that is great my one of my sons said to
me um
dad i didn't even know what you did
until i was like 16 or 17. because
all you kind of told me was that you
helped heal broken hearts
but he did say the first time he was
actually in the
the the place where i i i worked i
started
it's called this it was called the
center for professional excellence in
nashville
and the first time he was in the
building he said dad i thought
i was never allowed here never allowed
in this building so
so obviously he had taken the idea that
me not sharing enough
about what i did is it was you're in the
fbi or something that he had turned it
sort of into like it's not we can't talk
about it at the same time
i didn't burden them with
uh what all it meant right however if i
could change anything as a parent
i think that in where that when the fear
of what could happen
if they didn't uh stay focused if they
didn't
if we didn't stay above all the
addictive
impress of our society i think i pushed
a little too hard on
these things can happen if you don't if
you drink if you if
you if you get operated on and you're on
a narcotic i mean
you know i come from the addictions
world i mean i come literally
genetically from the addictions world
right so i mean i come from a background
i think sometimes that colored
my uh talk of theirs or treatment there
so
i would say i was a uh i end up probably
being a little
more controlling than i wish i'd been so
my dad was a homicide detective
and and in the same vein um
hopefully it gives you some peace um
i recognized one day that when it was
hey this could happen this could happen
this could happen
that in my world those things never
happen
ever his particular job your particular
job
your gifts to humanity were dealing with
the outside the bell curve situations
right all day every day and what i
noticed over the years is
that outside the bell curve stuff that
never happens
it happens ten times to six million
people in houston where we grew up
yeah those were the ten hours of his
monday and the ten hours of his tuesday
right so that was his entire bell curve
right
and it was when i shifted out and
thought oh he's just loving me the best
he knows how right
and what a gift that ended up being i
did
grow up thinking that someone's going to
be knocking on our door to to wipe us
out at any moment yeah
no the what the good the saving grace
about
you know is that i was able to implement
and practice the very things that
you know howard created so i had written
the voice of the heart
about uh first son was like eight at the
time so we've been practicing the
feelings
what a gift oh man you're not kidding so
i want to talk about that
this book when i first took this job at
ramsey solutions i walk in the door
ever multiple people like hey you got to
read this book this book's for you you
got to read this book
and not for me but for it i mean it's
and then i
you know it's on a second printing um
and
coming from a mental health background i
hadn't heard it and i sat through this
and i kept thinking how did i not
have i not heard this yeah um and so
there's some unique things can you give
a high level overview of this
yep high level overview the book says
that you and i are created
as emotional spiritual creatures created
to live fully
okay but we can't live fully unless
we're doing that in relationship
with ourselves others and god we've been
given eight tools
to be able to live fully in a tragic
place eight feelings
right right there there if you if you
if you don't know the primary colors you
can't become an artist
hmm right red yep yep red
blue and i don't know i've got a
four-year-old i should know that
exactly but i mean you can't be a
painter
if you don't know the core right it's a
mix and match
so these eight feelings aren't
restrictions they're actually the way we
end up creating the tones and the
multiplicity of living
but we have eight core feelings that let
us live fully in a tragic place
right fear is about our tragedy of life
loneliness hurt sadness anger is
actually what moves us through life
healthy shame guilt gladness i mean this
is
these are the tools that move us into
asking for
help i've heard two people in the world
say this and you're one of them the
other is rage against the machine
and you both say anger is a gift amen
tell me about that well rage and anger
are very separate
because as separate as uh say ocean is
from land
okay rage is a destructive
force that a person enacts to hide from
having to experience
terror to remove themselves from
re-experiencing
something they swore they'd never go
through again okay to keep from having
helplessness
anger is a feeling the most vulnerable
of all the feeling is the
energy moving towards whatever it is
that matters to me that's worth being in
pain over
okay anger is the most vulnerable
feeling of all because it shows what i
care about
synonyms for anger all vulnerable words
i hunger
i thirst i yearn i long i hope i dream
i wish i want i need all of those are
reaching
open hand help me show me tell me
and then the gift of anger which is the
voice of the heart
it's the voice of life i mean how did
all these become pathologies
well because i think one is one we write
prescriptions for every one of us
every one in three people according to
this internist i talked to
he said every one of the every three
people coming to my office right now are
coming in
to be medicated for depression or
anxiety anxiety
which means which which i know that
there's the clinical brain stuff of
those things
dude anxiety is just an alarm system it
just says you're out of whack and it
says also underneath that
is i'm afraid yes if i don't know what
to do with fear or haven't been trained
to acknowledge fear and seek help with
fear
then anxiety takes its place depression
takes the place of anger right or pride
when we depress the energy of our voices
when we push it down uh archimedes said
that
he discovered that a ball of air has an
equal and
and increased pressure to rise the more
you push it down right
right yep so it's like holding a holding
a rubber ball under water right yeah
exactly so we start using willpower and
our intellect and
and moral teachings to suppress
expression of how god made us
so the teachings of our life both
christian and non-christian
are both teaching us to hide from who
god made
and so when we give up our anger we're
giving up god yeah
if you understand anger in fact if you
look at philippians 4 8
it's an amazing test it says you know
brothers sisters
think on these things which really means
focus on desiring
right right let's let your head and
heart match because these are things
that matter whatever is lovely
pure true right just maybe adding to a
couple
but whatever is true whatever is
praiseworthy or
admirable the noble life seek it go
after it
let nothing stop you from it but if you
can't have your anger
if you can't have the passion or
willingness to be in pain for something
that matters more than pain
all those ideals are sunk because
there's no gasoline in that engine
no no and and also if you don't have
anger you can't express your hurt your
sadness your fear your loneliness right
like like when when i get rejected or
somebody hurts me
it's like ow man that hurt whether it's
physical or somebody
verbally right you know if you listen to
the words it's in the book but if you
listen to the words
that we used to describe the hurt of
life the rugs pulled out from under me
it blindsided me it was a it was like it
speared me
it went right through me i mean that's
violence yeah so i mean our hearts
are experiencing words even or looks
as wounds because we're so made to be
relationally connected
right if we hide our hurt we will bleed
to death
if we cry out and express our hurt we
can heal
and be stronger for it because the hurt
brings us to healing and healing brings
us to courage
i'm experienced and guess what i'm going
to still live
because i made it through i'm heading
back in and now i know how to do it
better
you always send an older soldier in with
younger soldiers
god knows hurt and healing and therefore
he has more wisdom and courage about how
to go do it
so it means so anger is amazing and and
i don't mean acting out
but we live in a society that's
terrified of feelings
just yeah and anger is the most
expressive of the feelings because it
says i am here
right and this matters to me and i have
these feelings
and i have this wish and i have this
desire and i have this longing
often people are going like oh boy
trouble just stepped
in here you know and so i've got 18
million different
numbing compression behaviors to get rid
of well that's well said
self-cures and we're we we have 10
million self cures
called addiction or compulsions and 20
million other people trying to sell me a
new one to get rid of
how i made now i don't disagree with
antidepressants on any level okay
but 187 million
prescriptions for the top three
antidepressants top three now there are
like 30. so the top three were written
in like 2016 or 15 or something
so i'm spearing been a near vertical
trend line since then even so yeah
and you've seen especially in the higher
education since 2013
bananas the the girl and boy population
in colleges
were anxiety and depression then in
2013-ish
the the rate for females went up because
of the left out missed out syndrome
i mean their social media is presenting
a world that they're not included in
so i i read anxiety is going like an
extraordinary book by robert saplowski
called behavior and he's a he's
a baboon researcher out of uh stanford
but he mentioned he talked about
something i've never read before and he
studied the same troupe of baboons over
30 years
and he talked about our standing
in whatever community we have is
co-regulated at all times
and he said it's the difference between
the assistant director of the mail room
that gets moved up to associate director
in their little group of 12
and they are like this and they feel
esteemed
and they feel included and they feel
appropriate
and the ceo or the the
the cfo that gets passed over to be the
ceo
and can only look at the one that made
it above them and not the 999 others
and it talked about we are all
co-regulated in our standing with other
people
and the moment they handed out those
boxes there was
never not somebody in the world that we
couldn't see that was better looking or
richer or faster or skinnier or whatever
than us
and it totally just regulated all of us
yeah instantly overnight yeah comparison
is the thief
of contentment right well man so good
ramsay andy
that's i'll keep my paycheck going one
more month man
i'm so grateful you came by and um it's
good to meet you today it's like we just
met
because this is how i like to be this is
a great way to meet
um where can people find you uh chip.com
okay
two d's yeah d-o-d-d get this
book people what's wrong with you get
the book people in the booth or wait
like get the book that's awesome yeah
there's the
needs of the heart parenting with heart
keeping heart
i love keeping heart it's about
reawakening to some old things we forgot
like your grandmother talked about
it talks about some of those things we
are not as smart as we think we are man
no man and you know what it's like um
i wrote a novel called uh anthem to the
invisible don't read it but get it on
audiobook okay
it it's about how it the ancient is
is always true it's the river of life we
gotta learn how to swim and float in
yeah see old roads going to the land is
hyperphoria
trying to control things or hypophoria
try not to care
yeah but in the river of life where
euphoria is burying life well
there's joy sadness hurt loss hope
connecting
life it just is it's where we're made to
live living fully
ah bless you man thank you john this is
john delony this is the stud dr chip
dodd
we'll talk to you soon the old old stud
don't forget the whole thing that's
right hey take care we'll see you soon
thank you